okay don't panic everyone I am in a in a
real studio I went from it's kind of a
it's it's a rags to riches story I went
from homeless in my car yelling into my
phone and then I was in my mom's
basement in front of a fake cardboard
fireplace and now I am at least
temporarily for a couple of days in a
studio of sorts it's just it's a
temporary thing I'm visiting LA and they
said yeah you can go in a studio if you
want you can have the makeup and all the
things and all that it's kind of like a
take your child to work day sort of
thing it's just they're just humoring me
with with this little setup so there's a
lot that we got to get to including the
justice Millette madness but before we
do that let's check in with Freedom
Project Academy this year nearly seventy
billion dollars okay think about that
seventy billion dollars of taxpayer
money will be spent on public education
yet a new report finds that just two and
five American students are ready to
attend college so to be perfectly frank
about it you're better off sending your
kids to go be raised by squirrels in the
woods for 13 years than you are in
sending them to public school that's
basically where we're at so many of you
are searching for a school that offers a
real education one that is
appreciatively better than what a
squirrel could provide a school with
traditional values that help students
develop strong foundations in math
science English American history but
most importantly with a school in the
idea with education is are teaching kids
how to think critically not just what to
think not regurgitating but actually how
to think well the search is over freedom
project Academy is an accredited online
school built on judeo-christian values
and classical curriculum for students
from kindergarten all the way through
high school so they do the whole thing
this is a complete interactive
educational experience where students
attend live classes with other students
so it's just like they're in a real a
real classroom a physical you know
classroom freedom project Academy
provides live and recorded lessons
homework tests tutoring grades
transcripts everything you could
possibly need so go to freedom for
school comm and request your free
information packet today that's freedom
for school comm and roll by March 31st
you've got five or six days to do this
and you get some discounted rates on
that don't forget to
subscribe to their weekly podcast the
dr. Duke show available on iTunes and
more take back control of your kids
education that's freedom for school comm
freedom for school comm freedom for
school comm freedom for school calm well
I was planning on I was flying up here
on the plane flying over here I should
say and I was planning on starting the
show I have to admit by doing a bit of
gloating about what a great week it's
been you know for right-wingers and what
a terrible week it's been for left
wingers but then this Smollett thing
happened and I think that the the timing
I imagine is not actually coincidental
just breaking this afternoon the State
Attorney's Office in Chicago has swooped
in to drop all of the charges against
Jesse Smollett now that office is headed
by a woman named Kim Fox and you may if
you've been following this amoled case
you may remember that name because we
were told about a month ago that she
recused herself from the investigation
and it wasn't exactly clear why she
recused herself but then we find out
that she's got some sort of connection
to the Smollett family but now she's
back and she's giving Smollett a walk so
the police department is furious the
mayor is furious I'll play those clips a
little bit later on and that is when I
talk about the police department let's
remember that the police department is
and I feel like I have to in this in
this day and age of identity politics I
have to make a note of the fact that the
police department is headed by a black
police chief so this is not a case of
you know racist white police officers
trying to railroad an innocent black man
that's not what's going on here at all
what did the prosecutor's office say to
to justify this decision to drop all the
charges well they haven't said a whole
lot but they did say this after
reviewing all the facts and
circumstances of the case including mr.
Smollett volunteer service in the
community and agreement to forfeit his
bond to the city of Chicago we believe
this out this outcome is a just
disposition and appropriate resolution
to the case notice what they're not
saying they're not saying that the
evidence that the evidence wasn't
sufficient they're certainly not saying
he didn't do it
all they're saying is that he's already
done some community service and so
there's no point in pursuing this that's
what they're saying that well yeah he'd
you know he tied up all these police
resources he he took advantage of racial
tensions he lied he did all that but you
know he's done some community service in
the past so yeah
that's essentially a statement they're
also keeping his bond they said in
reviewing the case smollett's agreement
to forfeit his bond is part of the
reason why they're letting him go now
that is an insane reason to let anyone
go I mean whether they're they're you
know innocent or not but it certainly
isn't a reason that you're giving if the
man is innocent an innocent man gets his
bond back that's the whole point and an
innocent man doesn't have to do any
community service either so this is not
what they say if it's just you're
brought up on charges and then they find
out that oh you know what there's no
there there they're like they're gonna
drop the charges it's not going to be
any talk of community service or or you
know you agreed to let them keep your
bond Joe maggots maggots I don't how to
pronounce it interestingly enough his
name is spelled maga TS so Magga TS
that's the Assistant State's State's
Attorney he has specifically clarified
this just happened recently that
Smollett is not exonerated this is not
an exoneration he says this is what he
said here's the thing we work to
prioritize violent crime and the drivers
of violent crimes Public Safety is our
number-one priority I don't see Jesse
Smollett as a threat to public safety we
stand behind the investigation we stand
behind the decision to charge him and we
stand behind the chart listen to this
part we stand behind the charges in the
case the mere fact that it was disposed
of in an alternative manner does not
mean that there were any problems or
infirmities in the case or the evidence
disposed of in an alternative manner
isn't that nice
if you ever get brought up on you know
if you ever commit a crime and wouldn't
be nice if they disposed of the charges
in an alternative manner that's very
interesting they're saying that they
stand behind the charges we stand behind
the charges but we're letting him go
translation they know that he's guilty
as hell but they're giving him a pass
anyway nitwit saw the left morons on the
left are celebrating as if Smollett has
been vindicated when actually the exact
opposite has happened did I just read
for you the statement they stand behind
the charges and it's not an exoneration
so not only does this not indicate his
innocence but it actually only further
indicates his guilt and it also
indicates the corruption of the judicial
system in Chicago which we already knew
about you've got the state's attorney's
office coming in interfering going
behind the police with departments back
to let a rich celebrity walk on charges
that she herself never claims were
erroneous and that actually they say
they stand behind now by the way this is
exactly what the left thought was going
to happen with the Muller investigation
what they said there what they were
worried about they said they told us for
two years what's going to happen is that
a biased third party is going in this
case Trump is going to interfere to shut
down an investigation despite
overwhelming evidence of guilt now that
didn't happen with Muller and Trump it
did happen with Smollett in the end it
turns out that it's always the liberals
who do the colluding have you noticed
that this is another case of collusion
so every time you hear liberals talk
about collusion it is always projection
because what you know what they're
really upset about they're upset you're
treading they or they think that we're
treading on their territory because what
they're saying is no that's you guys
aren't supposed to do that that's our
thing that's our move okay get your own
moves
if you're wondering whether justice
existent exists in this world consider
this case and consider that Smollett
will will now be worshipped as a hero on
the left and you already see that
developing he'll get his job back in
fact he'll probably get the raise that
he did all of this to attain in the
first place and the left is to embrace
him now well unless they are total
absolute brain-dead idiots which is
possible but they're not all that okay
the ones who are not brain-dead idiots
they know that he's guilty but they're
going to overlook the fact that he's
guilty they're gonna overlook the
injustice that was done here they're
going to overlook the fact that Smollett
exploited racial tensions and did all
this stuff for his own gain and they're
going to overlook it for ideological
region reasons as usual so let me play a
couple of clips for you here here's um
here's my let's gloating outside of the
courthouse
I've been truthful and consistent on
every single level since day one I would
not be my mother son if I was capable of
one drop of what I was accused of this
has been an incredibly difficult time
honestly one of the worst of my entire
life
but I'm a man of faith and I'm a man
that has knowledge of my history and I
would not bring my family our lives or
the movement who a fire like this
I just wouldn't okay I could only I
could only stomach so much of that what
an absolute sociopath but he wins let's
face it and why does he win well he
certainly doesn't win because he's
innocent the evidence against him was
and is overwhelming including the fact
that his two friends admitted to the
whole thing okay they've got the
accomplices confessed and said yeah this
is what happened have you noticed that
they're not resolving Smollett and his
attorney and the prosecutor they haven't
resolved to go out and find the real
culprits and find out who are these
racist white people that are prowling
the streets looking for black people to
assault nobody is saying that they want
to go find those people why is that
that's because they know that the real
culprit is the guy who just waltzed out
of the building a free man
in fact SMO lets lawyers today came out
and in an in a really incredible
admission they admitted that the
Nigerian brothers the Friends of
Smollett who were arrested and they're
the ones who confessed to this whole
thing and and and spilled the beans
his lawyers today in the press
conference admitted that they were the
ones who attacked Smollett so they said
that Smollett yes okay Smollett was
attacked by these two Nigerians who
Smollett knows yet somehow his attorneys
claimed that Smollett wasn't lying well
hold on a second if I'm not crazy I
thought the whole thing here was that
Smollett said that it was two white
racists who attacked him and shouted
this is Magga country right so to
believe in smollett's innocence here's
what you have to believe you have to
believe that two Nigerian friends of
Smollett decided to randomly assault him
on the street at 2:30 a.m. and you know
in the morning in December and scream
this is mega country and that Smollett
not only did not recognize them as his
friends but didn't even recognize them
as Nigerian and instead thought that
they were white that's you're gonna have
to accept that if you want to believe in
small that's innocence and that is
simply impossible to believe so back to
the question why does he win why does he
get away with it the answer I think gets
us closer to understanding the true
nature of privilege in this country he
gets away with it first of all because
he's rich and famous all right there is
a two-tier justice system in this
country there is the track that you that
you know pleads like you and me we'll be
on if we commit a crime we're gonna be
on the normal track and if we did it and
they have evidence we're gonna go to
jail for it we're gonna face the
consequences and then there's another
tear for people like Jesse Smollett who
have the money and have the clout and
the fame and all that kind of stuff
so don't don't make the mistake of
thinking that oh so okay so now we're
allowed to file false police reports and
now I'm gonna go and file false police
reports until my heart's content no
don't don't make that mistake because
you need to get it few TV gigs first and
then and then maybe get a high-rise
apartment somewhere in Chicago and then
maybe you can get away with it although
even then you might not get away with it
because you know think about this James
Woods let's just say is a famous
celebrity right white conservative
celebrity I assume pretty wealthy well
do you think that if he had fabricated a
story about two liberal black men
assaulting him and you know on the
street corner do you think that if he
had made up that story he would have
faced no consequences for it no of
course he would have because there's one
other factor that matters here and that
factor is identity politics Smollett has
everything going for him he has
wealthiest Fame he has a whole fist full
of victim tokens by virtue of his of his
race and his sexual orientation and he's
a liberal he's a Trump hater I refer you
back to the victimhood flowchart that we
talked about a few a few weeks ago
well Smollett just has too many
victimhood points he is simply
untouchable which is why there was
really never any chance of him facing
real justice especially in a place like
Chicago and the state's attorney's
office they may have well just they may
as well just come out and said did you
really think we're gonna prosecute this
guy come on come on
that's their whole statement should have
just been that come on guys what did you
think was gonna happen and I would have
respected that I would I would have
respected that statement a lot more
because at least it's honest I want to
play a couple other clips for you
because not everyone in Chicago is
taking this lying down
so here's Rahm Emanuel mayor of Chicago
speaking out where is the accountability
in the
you cannot have because of a person's
position one set of rules apply to them
and another set of rules apply to
everybody else in another way you're
seeing this play out in the universities
where people pay extra to get their kids
a special position in universities now
you have a person because of their
position and background who's getting
treated in a way that nobody else would
ever sorry about that
what don't get near I'm doing near my
sermon here that would ever get close to
this type of treatment okay so he's he's
pretty angry and it's nice to see that
from him I wasn't expecting that to be
honest and here is the the police chief
who also is not happy about this so
listen um I'm sure we all know what
occurred this morning not personal
opinion is that you all know where I
stand on this do I think justice was
served
no where do I think justice is I think
this city is still old an apology and
let me digress one when I came on this
job I've been the cotton out for about
31 years when I came on this job
I came on with my honor my integrity and
my reputation someone accused me of
doing anything that was circumvent that
and I would want my day in court
period to clear my name
I've heard that they wanted their day in
court with TV cameras so America could
know the truth and though they chose to
hide behind secrecy and broker a deal to
circumvent the judicial system my job as
a police officer is to investigate an
incident gather evidence gather the
facts and presenting to the states of
time that's what we did I stand behind
the detectives investigation I'll let
Mary manin comment further
now remember that these are Democrats
okay at least rahm emanuel is I don't
know about the police chief I kind of
assume he is because it would be really
hard to get to a position of leadership
in a place like Chicago if you're a
conservative but even these guys are
saying that this is bogus and that it's
wrong and it's a fraud
so to summarize let's say there's a new
rule now okay the new rule is you aren't
allowed to complain about wealth and
privilege and wealth disparity if you're
cheering this on and if you go on social
media right now you're gonna find a lot
of social justice warriors a lot of
liberals who are very very happy that a
a wealthy celebrity has gotten away with
committing a crime by virtue of his
wealth and his fame and and his
privilege and so that's just that's just
not gonna work all right I want to go
back to to Muller for Moeller for a
moment
Muller Muller Smollett Smollett I don't
smell it Smollett how do you know who
I'm talking about and I want to talk
again about the implosion of the news
media there's a report in The New York
Times about news media leaders who are
trying to defend their
performance in recent months and years
especially with regard to the Russian
collusion case various people were
interviewed in this report in the New
York Times but I want to Zone in on Jeff
Zucker who's the president of CNN now
CNN the clowned itself perhaps worst of
all but if you're thinking that sucker
is ready to come out and take
accountability and it admit his faults
and pledge to do better or whatever no
he's about as about as apologetic as
maletas so this is what he told the
times now this is a really incredible
quote okay this is again I emphasize
this is from a the president of an
alleged news organization okay he says
we are not investigators we are
journalists and our role is to report
the facts as we know them which is
exactly what we did a sitting presidents
own Justice Department investigated his
campaign for collusion with a hostile
nation that's not enormous because the
media says so that's enormous because
it's unprecedented
now did you did you catch that we're not
investigators we're journalists this is
a fascinating statement it's it's as if
a surgeon went to perform an operation
on you with his hands still smothered in
like barbeque sauce from the from the
ribs that he had at lunch and you go hey
doc can you wash your hands before you
cut me open please and he said hey man
what do I look like a hygienist I'm not
a hygienist okay I'm a doctor yeah but
you're kind of a hygienist too if you're
a surgeon I mean it comes with the
territory doesn't it you can't properly
treat people which is your job if you're
spreading the infection and you're
spreading diseases so something similar
could be said about journalists your job
is to report the truth but you can't
report the truth if you
first find out the truth now I shouldn't
have to explain this to someone like
Jeff Zucker who again is a the president
of a news organization and if you want
to find out the truth that is going to
entail some form of investigation but if
you don't investigate before reporting
you're just in spread your spreading
infections you're spreading disease
you're spreading fake news and
misinformation and propaganda so yes
in a journalist is an investigator I
mean this quote you see being you see
being tossed around online all the time
about how you know journalists are like
courageous firefighters that are running
towards the fire
well yeah you're not just running
towards the fire to gawk at it right
you're supposed to be running towards
the fire figuring out what's going on
set the fire you know figuring out all
the details so there's going to be some
element of investigation
you know so if I know this if I
understand this basic fact about news
reporting it's very disturbing that the
guy who runs CNN does not understand it
and that really tells you everything you
need to know I mean everything you need
to know about about the modern news
media has been just been distilled right
there in those two sentences we're not
investigators we're journalists and as I
talked about yesterday that that is
actually very true that at least these
days that's the case we're now you know
investigation and journalism are seen as
these two mutually exclusive pursuits
and in most cases yeah a journalist
although we should be an investigator is
not he's more of in an entertainer or or
a you know a propagandist a smear
merchant many times but not an
investigator so Jeff Zucker unwittingly
told a very profound truth there all
right finally I I have to play what
without doubt without hype I think the
most Awkward 45 second video clip that
you will ever see in your entire life
take the cringe East
moments in a show like The Office and
ramped it up to 11 and this is so much
worse because it's real as far as I know
now before I play this let me give you a
little bit of a little bit of a setup
Pope Francis was celebrating Mass as he
does and afterwards he formed a greeting
line to say hello to the pilgrims who
came out to to see him well standard
protocol if you're not Catholic maybe
you don't know this but standard
protocol if you're Catholic is when you
meet the Pope you're supposed to kiss
his ring now the Pope I assume knows
this because he's been Pope for like
seven years I think six or seven years
but it appears that he's not a fan of
that particular protocol so this is just
unbelievable watch this
oh my sweet heaven I really first time I
saw that I almost cringed so hard that I
nearly collapsed into myself and formed
a black hole that would have sucked
everything into itself and obliterated
existence as we know it almost I have so
many questions about this number one if
if Pope Francis doesn't want to do the
ring kissing thing then why doesn't he
have his people make an announcement
like publish the new protocol 'he's
right let everybody know that you don't
do that so they don't make fools of
themselves has he really been doing that
for seven years and the thing is every
time you see if you saw the video every
time someone tried to kiss his ring he
lurched back like he was shocked he was
like what are you doing hey man he
reacted like I would react if I went to
you know go shake someone's hand in a
social situation they and they leaned in
to kiss my hand I would about whoa hey I
don't know where you're from we don't do
that around here that's how he reacted
but this is people have been kissing his
ring for seven years second question I
understand why the first couple of
people got rejected but wouldn't the
fourth or fifth person in line start to
figure it out I mean you're all in line
if you see all these people getting
rejected by the time it gets to you
wouldn't you just go in for the fist
bump or something why do you still lunge
for the for the rink is it seems like
they were really desperate to kiss his
ring number three this isn't really a
question but a statement the Pope's
behavior here is truly inexcusable I
mean it's it's kind of hilarious but
it's also inexcusable even if you don't
like the ring kissing thing the fact is
that that these people apparently
weren't told that he doesn't do it and
this was their one chance to meet the
Pope and I'm sure they were really
excited but then this is what happens
they get rejected their one encounter
with the Pope was probably the most
awkward cringe east encounter they've
ever had in their life with anyone it's
it's it you know if the president had
some weird
not wanting to shake people's hands I
would respect that um
I respect germophobes I respect people
who don't like to make physical contact
with anyone in any situation except for
close family members I'm that way you
know I never want their are about you
know five or six people in my life who I
ever want within like it's like this is
my you can't come closer than this for
me unless I know you very very well so I
respect that but let's say the President
had a thing like that well then it's his
responsibility to tell people that so
they know ahead of time so there's not
an awkward thing where people go to
shake his hand then and then there's
that you know when you go to shake
someone's hand they don't shake yours
and it's kind of like this you know and
you don't know what to do with your
hands
so I think that's the Pope's
responsibility fourth point I'll make
about this is as a Catholic and I know
that I may lose some Catholic street
cred in saying this but although I think
the Pope handled this terribly I would
be fine with getting rid of the whole
the whole ring kissing rigmarole I do
find it a little strange I know that see
what what Catholics will say is well
it's it's not a sign of deference to the
man it's a sign of deference to the
office which which is I get that which
is fine but as human you see as human
beings we don't really deal well with
abstract concepts like in office right
we deal with people and so inevitably
even if we talk about respect the office
have pay homage to the office it's it's
really going to end up being know where
we are paying homage to the man who
holds the office we can't help but do
that we can't help but draw that
connection because as I said we don't
deal in abstracts we deal and what is
personal and right in front of us so I
think that a lot of the pomp and
circumstance surrounding the Pope I
think in many ways it sends the wrong
message and I think that these men in
leadership positions in the church could
do well to to
be humbled and to be treated more like
just regular men because at the end of
the day that's what they are they're
just men like you and I so any effort to
inject some humility and take out some
of the pomp and circumstance I think
that's a good thing I don't know if it's
really helped matters especially in
recent in recent years and I say that
that doesn't just go for the Catholic
Church by the way now other churches
might not have the the ring kissing bit
but there are there are churches that in
effect have that there are plenty of
other churches other denominations where
the pastors are treated like like
celebrities like their own little gods
and in other churches like mega churches
the pastors they might live in big
mansions and people go and they they
treat the pastor like he's a you know
the lead singer of a boy band or
something like that
and and and that doesn't help either
that's no good either and that's
certainly not in keeping with the with
jesus's style let's just say all right
let's go to some emails you can always
email the show of course at Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com don't think that just because
I'm in this fancy studio that you can't
send me emails and now I'm
unapproachable or something it's still
it's still just me okay this is from
Lisa says you read my email on your show
today and you said that's where this
came in yesterday you may read my email
on your show today and you said that
teacher raises should be given on a
case-by-case basis while I understand
that argument the public school system
is too broken for that to work here's
why the raises would come from the
school administration and they define
teacher success by their student failure
rate exclusively as I've already in my
experience as a teacher as I've seen
already in my experience teachers will
get easy work will give a easy work and
hand out A's as grades just so their
failure rate is low and administration
is happy with them
admin doesn't care about anything else
so if you're a good teacher who actually
holds students accountable for their
learning you probably will have a
slightly higher failure rate admin does
not like this because it puts the school
state funding and Jeff
to admin you are immediately a bad
teacher if you have a failure rate
higher than they like and that's simply
not the case especially if you teach a
hard subject and students are on their
phones the whole time refusing to learn
so if admin is in charge of the raises
then the do-nothing teachers you
described as giving out worksheets and
never teaching would get all the raises
and the good teachers who actually care
about the about learning would not that
would definitely not encourage them to
stay or even encourage them to become a
do-nothing teacher themselves if they
see it works for their lazy colleagues
basically the system is too broken for
improvement and needs to be demolished
so this is coming from someone in the
system who's saying the system is broken
and needs to be demolished and I have to
tell you that I get so many emails from
teachers and people who are in the
public school system because I talk
about this kind of these kinds of issues
all the time and you would be shocked or
maybe you wouldn't be if you saw just
how many teachers will say exactly that
to me they'll say listen I'm in this
system and it's a disaster zone that's
very concerning but I appreciate your
honesty there Lisa
here's another teacher chiming in this
is from well of course I had to get this
person's name well it says hi Matt I
love your podcasts I just wanted to
chime in on on your discussion about
teacher salary I am a second year
teacher teaching kindergarten in a high
in a high poverty charter school in Ohio
that being said I worked there on
purpose many teachers do I want you to
know that I wholeheartedly agree with
most everything you've said regarding
teacher compensation here's the sitch
one every teacher in America knows the
deal before they sign up for it you can
google median teacher salary any minute
you please I didn't start teaching and
think wait one day a minute where are
the riches I was promised if you're
trying to make a lot of money cool don't
be a teacher too but teachers have the
most important job in America they mold
the future they need to be paid more
hell yes my job is extremely important
and the perks I enjoy from it are
extremely rare compared to other
professions a into work at 7:30 out by
3:30 B you can tell this person's a
teacher by the way how they've organized
their their email it's great a into work
at 7:30 out by 3:30 B federal holidays
random
days off at at least once a month see
fall break Thanksgiving break Christmas
break spring break summer vacation I
mean come on D children come to work
with you and ride home with you three
wait though teachers don't really work
for only eight hours a day they work way
more than that yep we definitely do but
again this is the profession you chose
you knew you knew going in that teaching
is a unique profession I work many
evenings and most weekends newsflash
because I want to for okay but still
even with all those ridiculous benefits
teachers don't make enough money to pay
their bills
um I make forty four thousand that's
enough to pay the bills including the
monumental loan debt that I knowingly
signed on to incur the debt pay the debt
additionally some teachers suck like
really suck raising wages across the
board is ridiculous performance-based
raises yes blind raises for people who
teach because you can literally glide on
without being questioned how about no I
think teacher burnout occurs from having
to perform not only as a teacher but as
a stand-in parent this is the failing of
the family and it goes on from there
it's just a great email concerning email
in many respects but but great and very
honest and the you know the last two
emails that I read this is what I was
talking about yesterday these are there
there are really great teachers out
there who as I've said many times are up
against it because they're up against a
broken system and they're also up
against as this as this email or
mentioned they're up against these
parents who don't do any parenting and
then they send their awful kids into
school and the awful kids behave awfully
and and what happens when the teachers
try to deal with that problem and
instill some discipline well now that
the parents are going to swoop in and
finally take an interest in their child
in order to come to their defense and
interfere with the discipline so that
it's not anything that I would want to
deal with that's for sure finally this
is from Phil says since you have three
children do you find it easier to raise
one sex over the other this is an
interesting question and I in the
standard answer to this question is that
boys are way easier and I'm
going to agree wholeheartedly with the
standard answer I have a five year old
boy a two year old boy plus a five year
old girl and the boys are no big deal
honestly it's just like having a couple
of like rabid raccoons running around
the house it's a they just the climbing
things knocking things over eating
everything omitting strange odors all
the time but it's pretty straightforward
and you know how to deal with them and
plus I I know what kind of games to play
with them and everything one of our
favorite games is we call it tackling
and it's a really interesting game we do
we just go outside we'd run in circles
and tackle each other and and that's the
game but my daughter is much more
complex she's she's more she's more like
having I don't know a really moody cat
or something in the house if you've ever
been around a cat they always seem like
they're up in their head like they're
plotting it's kind of like that what
having a girl and she gets upset for
reasons that are often mysterious to me
and I can't snap it out of her by making
a farting noise like I can do with the
boys she's a lot trickier than my son
like she can hatch these various schemes
and plots and enlist her brother into
them and then and then set him up as the
fall guy when it all goes to when it all
goes to hell it's impressive that she
could do that at five but it's also sort
of terrifying I will say she's much more
helpful around the house like she's
she's my son is useless when it comes to
chores but my daughter likes to clean
and cook and do dishes and fold laundry
and all that kind of stuff she's very
helpful very smart very joyful when she
wants to be but also prone to drastic
and mysterious mood swings and she's
terrifyingly adept at manipulation so
she's a girl in other words and God
loved her and God loved them all but it
is the greatest joy in the world to have
these raccoons and cats running around
your house we'll leave it there thanks
everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed hey everyone its
Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin
show how is it the press so disgraced
itself in their miss coverage of the
Russian non collusion scandal ease
they didn't cover the corruption of the
Obama administration who appointed all
the clowns who got the scandal rolling
Obama will take a look on the Andrew
Klavan show I'm Andrew Clayton